hello and welcome to Strasbourg capital
of the French region of Alsace sitting
on the border with Germany and with not
a little touch of Venice about it and is
home to the landmark European Parliament
where decisions are taken by members
representing you and me once a month
during its plenary session
have you ever wondered what goes on
behind the scenes at these penry
sessions well follow me for so we're
going to start in Brussels let's wind
the clock back for just a moment to the
preceding week here in Brussels and the
huge amount of preparatory work that
goes into making sure the plenaries run
smoothly and deliver the intended
political objectives VIP visits the
award of prizes celebrating European
liberty and culture key votes and
debates but it doesn't just happen just
like that there's a quiet constant
repulsing engine at work here a lot of
it is centered around the monthly
plenary session here for example where
hard politics and hard compromises are
the business of the day moderated by a
senior member of the Parliament
Secretariat each political group
discusses which debates and which folks
are to appear on the plenary agenda
without majority agreement it simply
doesn't happen so what is on the agenda
well today's issues include Europe's
position in the climate change summit in
Lima in Peru violence against women and
a right-wing motion of censure against
the entire Commission of jean-claude
Juncker we are civil servants are here
to assist in the political process to
guarantee also the rights of minorities
guarantee that parliamentary procedures
are carried out in a democratic way and
then we are there also with a view to
ensuring that when the group leaders
meet on Thursday in the week before
Strasburg that they can concentrate on
the political issues Thursday is when
the conference of presidents of
political groups meets with the
president of the Parliament Martin
Schulz to set the final agenda anything
else arises subsequently it has to be
disclosed at the plenary and agreed by M
eps okay that's some of the preparations
that take place in Brussels we're
actually back here in Strasbourg for the
plenary session of November and we want
to go backstage and who better to take
us backstage then Pascal whew Wow yes
one of the 60 Usher's I think in the
European Parliament Pascal how long have
you been
for here I work for the parliament since
15 years okay well let's go in and have
a look at some of the nuts and bolts and
the mechanics of the plenary session you
can explain to me what happens we're
okay this is the chamber of European
Parliament we are here 751 members
elected by people around the Europe this
is a Gary all the people from outside
can come in the European Parliament just
to follow the debate of the European
Parliament we can have per day more or
less than 2,000 people talk me through
the breakdown of the way MEP sit here so
you have on the middle deliver on yeah
the green the socialist and from this
part you are DPP group yeah so it's very
easy to see from podium of the president
when they want to vote something they
are easy for him to see just ya gotta
take care of this thing over there
because they think is for the voting of
the European members yeah yes when
should use this voting card over there
and then you can vote you can put first
the meanest of the neutron let me ask
you a question do you see here in the
European Parliament a different way of
doing politics party politics that you
would have say compared to the
Parliament in your home country France
or Parliament's that you may see another
totally old front house every front it's
less aggressive i would say to be for us
to final agreement between different
country between different culture you
know the vote makes or breaks European
legislation and the system that makes it
all go smoothly in real time with
everyone knowing what's going on is here
a sort of engine room within an engine
room let's go behind the scenes and meet
vrl Kozma administrator of voting
services it's a very sophisticated
technology we follow what the president
is saying in the Indy original we don't
follow the interpretation because it
would be too slow when the voting
terminals are enabled the members can
cast their vote we wait for several
seconds in this lapse of time they can
change their minds they can change their
vote expression and then we display the
results the next plenary of course will
be entirely different different debates
and issues different personalities
appearing before
wholly-owned one thing will remain the
same however the continually turning
machinery that makes it all happen